this is the Fox News Alert the New York
Times now reporting former New York City
Mayor Michael Bloomberg is expected to
file for the Alabama presidential
primary the deadline tomorrow
it's fueling more speculation that
Bloomberg is preparing to run in 2020
Katie what do you make of this well the
deadline is tomorrow so this could be an
insurance policy after we get past the
next debate which is November 20th for
him to look at the field and see if it's
weak enough that he can maybe get in
there's been a lot of talk about whether
the frontrunner can really make it
whether Joe Biden can go to over the
finish line beat Trump Elizabeth Warren
with this massive 52 trillion dollar
medicare-for-all plan and even Hillary
Clinton has been asked in recent weeks
if she's willing to jump in she says
she's not taking up professional running
at this time so it is interesting we'll
see if he ends up filing for other
states to kind of solidify him getting
in but it could be either an insurance
policy or a serious pursuit of the
nomination but Sondra what I'd heard was
that he was concerned about Biden that
he didn't think Biden was in particular
was doing very well in the debates so is
this a sign of democratic anxiety about
Joe Biden who remains nationally
believes what the report is is that he
is expected to go early file because the
deadline is tomorrow but according to
the report he's been privately weighing
a bid now for weeks
and has not yet made a final decision on
whether to run the New York Times also
talking about if he does enter the race
he would really deepen the debate on the
Democratic stage about income inequality
corporate power in America he's a very
very wealthy businessman and former New
York City Mayor it could change a lot of
things yeah he can also be looking at
there's no way he gets the nomination at
all I think this is great news for the
Republican Party it's going to cause
chaos in the Democratic primary he's a
multi-billionaire
who's gonna make these other Democrats
have to spend even more money which they
don't have especially Joe Biden this
hurts Joe Biden more than anybody
because Joe Biden's got that middle lane
this is Bloomberg's so-called middle
lane and Biden right now is a terrible
mess if you look at him on the debate
stage Bernie's a radical socialist and
Liz Warren is now so compromised herself
with stealing away 108
people's health care plan that I don't
see any of them making it and if you
believe these polls that show all these
people beating Donald Trump in a general
then why are all these people trying to
get in well it's just not true this is a
weak field it's one more thing quickly
on the politics here Michael Bloomberg
dumped a whole lot of money into
Virginia to turn it into a business
state on the issue of gun control and he
did it so that could also be playing
into his decision to file for the
president so Gregg do we have this is
the rebellion of the billionaires who
got Tom Styer or not potentially Michael
Bloomberg you know there's just too many
people in this hot tub they're all hairy
and old now my kind of hot tub wait so
you wouldn't vote three though I
actually don't mind Bloomberg even
though he's kind of a nanny he was a
nanny mayor he was telling people how to
live he's constantly enacting new rules
and regulations I don't know if he was
part of the selling of single banning
the selling of single cigarettes I don't
know if that was him so I shouldn't say
any more but you didn't like it you
didn't realize how good of a mayor he
was and I told ya let's change the
subject
we're gonna we're gonna apply after
those developments for you as they break